[MUSIC PLAYING]
TANAY BUDDHDEV: Hello, and
welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Tanay Buddhdev, and
I work in our Cloud customer
engineering team as a security
and compliance specialist.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let me just start by
thanking you all for your time
and joining us.
Also, since we're covering a
decent amount of information
in a short amount
of time, I just
want to remind everyone that
everything that we go over
today in this
session is something
that is going to be covered in
greater detail at our Google
Cloud Security and
Compliance website
or web page in the form of
articles and/or white papers.
So in this session
a few of us will
be talking about how a big
cloud computing company really
approaches things like security
as a whole, compliance, sharing
data securely, and working
securely from anywhere,
and what that really
means for you.
So I wanted to first
start by focusing
on some of the foundations,
so let's get started.
It really begins with
a single question
that every organization
should be asking themselves--
do you have a comprehensive
approach to security?
Now, this is probably a question
you've heard plenty of times.
And I know that CEOs
are often asked this
by their board of directors
because they tell us
all the time.
And here's how we've
learned to talk about it.
So it really started with
Google being born and raised
in the cloud and has
always run its services
in a multi-tenant cloud
environment for that time
and moving forward.
We're now fortunate
enough to actually
have seven global services
with 1 billion users each.
As a result, then,
you can imagine,
we're a pretty focused
target for bad actors.
So as you can
imagine, also then,
having to figure out security,
privacy, and data compliance
at such a large or
global scale is something
that we had to do
quickly and effectively
and not just do it
for the present time
but also future-proof it.
The learnings we've
had from these problems
really have turned into
the fundamental pillars
for how we design and secure our
infrastructure, which happens
to be the same infrastructure
that our enterprise
customers can and do use.
So because of our relentless
focus on protecting the user,
we've learned and built
systems in our infrastructure
that now enable
things such as what
you're seeing on your screen.
Now, as you can see, we're
making some bold statements
here.
Well, how are we able
to do these things?
So the vision and
the solution really
starts and comes down to a
single enterprise technology
platform that automates many
of today's security practices.
And it frees IT teams to
innovate and serve better
in other areas of
the enterprise.
It's what we use
at Google today,
and it's how we're actually
able to serve the seven Google
businesses with 1
billion customers each
that we talked about, along
with much of the world's media
and advertising businesses,
without suffering
the kind of security breaches
that typically put others
in news headlines.
Because it's a single
platform without the versions
and the layers of different
technology that create the most
security gaps, really, we have
speed and scale that others
simply just don't.
Every machine is
up-to-date, it's patched,
it's always available
and accounted for,
and there is no
planned downtime.
And actually, the
cool part is you
can take advantage
of this technology
with a feature we call
"live migration," something
that our customers that
I talk to all the time
are pretty excited about.
Because the platform works
with massive amounts of data,
it securely and safely
manages that data
with sophisticated encryption
at rest and in transit.
And because we believe the
cloud extends to on-premise data
centers, as well
as user devices,
it really turns the employees
from the greatest source
of risk to really your
front line defenders.
To get a little bit more into
detail with our approach,
take a look at this.
We actually call this
"defense in depth."
And the idea, really, is to
protect your organization
by eliminating holes, gaps,
and flaws at every layer,
whether that be the
infrastructure, the software,
or the processes.
I'll touch on a few of
those with some examples
and from the bottom up.
So let's get started.
So to begin with, every
layer is protected
using custom-built hardware
with no unnecessary parts.
Google manufactures almost
all of its own hardware.
And any third party never sees
the overall build process.
Last year, we deployed
and introduced
a security chip called Titan.
What Titan does-- and it's
installed in every Google
server--
it really checks every
machine for integrity
every time while
it's booting up.
And now in that
case, a server is not
allowed to jump on
the network, it's
holding and processing zero
data until its health has
been established.
And that's every single time.
Wherever possible,
we automate things.
So we're relentlessly
and repeatedly
checking code for
vulnerabilities
before it's deployed.
We automatically encrypt
data at rest and in transit
using our large and fast global
network that I was telling you
earlier about.
We maintain a system of
employee permissions,
and we keep all the
machines in the same state.
We have a massive team of
dedicated security engineers
and scientists
that are constantly
testing the environment
for vulnerabilities
and researching
patterns to figure out
what future vulnerabilities
or threats could look like so
that we can protect
Google well in advance.
So I've talked about
our infrastructure.
I've talked about our network.
I've talked about our data
management capabilities,
and our automation
at scale, and not
to forget, our incredible,
innovative security team,
but our vision for the cloud
does not really end here.
We also include your
on-premise data centers
in our security vision.
So we've developed things
such as Cloud Identity, which
can help you manage
access and permissions
on and off the cloud
with audit trails
so you can actually
stop bad actors
and establish
compliant policies.
Kubernetes, which hopefully all
of you have heard of by now--
a pretty popular
product nowadays,
and it's something that is
used for managing software
containers inside
our data center,
inside your data center, or
across both, if you like.
And containers is really
what makes possible
the kind of system-wide
automation of patches
that we were talking
about earlier.
Now, to give IT teams
better visibility
into how software
is used, it enables
them to innovate
and inform others
on things such as cost
performance and customer
product usage.
You may know that Kubernetes
is available on other platforms
as well.
Well, that's because when it
was being developed at Google
we open-sourced it so that we
could actually make something
as innovative and secure as
this available to the rest
of the community
and the industry,
kind of much the way we
did with Chrome, which
is the most secure browser.
So Istio, which is, again,
an open-source platform that
Google contributes to and
has done a lot of work with--
and it provides a uniform way
to connect, manage, and secure
microservices.
So a lot of customers
that I talked
with that are doing
containerization love Istio,
and they typically go
hand-in-hand together.
And lastly, one of
the things that's
also popular with some of the
customers I've talked to--
especially when they're focused
on on-premise to begin with--
is Apigee, which is really
what something that enables
you to do more with your data.
You can securely manage API
calls with other databases,
whether it's your
own or another one,
depending on your
strategic need.
So most of our customers
really start here
and use Apigee
extensively at first
to connect their on-premise
systems and applications
with Google Cloud.
So as you can see on most
of these things we're
talking about is, open
source, transparency,
and interoperability is a
core value at Google Cloud.
While we think our technology,
such as Google Kubernetes
Engine, is a really
effective way to go,
we're still big
believers in portability.
So we believe that you should
take your workloads with you,
if you choose to move,
and our customers should
be able to really move amongst
multiple cloud providers
if they choose to,
or do it all together
in a hybrid environment,
and choose providers
that really give you the best
and most innovative services.
So all this really
brings us down
to some of the last thoughts
I wanted to leave you with,
which is our Cloud
trust principles.
There's about five
of them that I
want to talk to you
about before I pass
the mic on to our next speaker.
So let's begin
with the first one.
Know that your security comes
first in everything that we do.
Secondly, you control
what happens to your data
every time.
Third, know where
Google stores your data,
and rely on it being available
every single time you need it.
Fourthly, depend on Google's
independently-verified security
practices.
And last but not least,
trust that we'll never
give any government entity
backdoor access to your data
or to any of our servers
that are storing your data.
So I know we've covered
a lot of information
in a short amount of time here
about how Google approaches
and secures our
own infrastructure
and what that means
for you, but don't just
take our word for it.
We believe in earning your
trust through transparency
and not just with the technology
we've been talking about.
So what I'm going
to do is, I'm going
to pass the mic on and leave you
in the capable hands of James
Snow, who's going to talk
to you about how Google
Cloud approaches audits,
compliance, and what that means
for you.
Thank you for your time.
JAMES SNOW: Thanks, Tanay,
and hello, everyone.
I'm James Snow.
I'm here to talk to you today
about security and compliance
on the Google Cloud Platform.
Now, to start, the first
question we often have
is, what can Google
do with data once it's
been put onto our
platform, otherwise known
as scope of processing?
The answer is very
straightforward.
Google can only use
data on our platform
to provide the service that you
as a customer have requested.
So we can only use the
data per your instructions.
And we can use it
for no other purpose.
So this is outlined, not
only in our contracts,
but it's also audited
by third parties,
but we'll get to that
in just a moment.
Next is intellectual property.
Who owns the
intellectual property
for data that is either uploaded
or generated on our platform?
Again, a very simple answer.
The customer has 100% of the IP
rights while Google has none.
Last but not least, especially
relevant in regulated industry
is around data portability.
So if you move data onto
the Google Cloud Platform,
can you easily move it off?
And the answer is, yes.
At any given time,
you can move your data
on or off our platform
without requiring assistance
from Google, with no
fines or fees, et cetera.
And of course, this comes off
in industry-standard formats.
You could think of Kubernetes,
our container orchestration
platform, as the ultimate
embodiment of this philosophy,
where you can move an
active workload from on-prem
to Google's clouds
to other clouds
dynamically in order to
meet uptime requirements.
To pivot and talk about
managing regulatory risk-- so
oftentimes, working with
regulated customers that
could be anything from
national regulation to health
care to government to finance.
There are lots of
different regulatory risks
that customers are exposed to.
Now, if you were to
think like a regulator,
the questions that
they're going to be asking
is, how are you protecting
your regulated data?
Who owns that data?
Where is it located, and
how is it being used?
Last but not least, if the
data is supposed to be deleted,
how is that done
securely and efficiently?
Now, at Google we have
a single cloud platform.
So this actually makes it easier
for a lot of regulated industry
because we operate a
baseline of security controls
across our entire platform.
So it's not one solution has one
level security or one product
has one level security.
It applies across
our entire platform.
We already covered
ownership and usage.
The customer owns the
data, and it can only
be used per their instructions.
Data location is
configurable per product
that we have on the
Google Cloud Platform.
At all times, it is
going to be transparent,
and customers will know where
their data is at any given
moment.
Data deletion-- so Google is
what we call a data processor.
The customer is the
data controller.
If the data controller
gives Google an instruction
to delete data, we as
the data controller
will execute their instruction
faithfully and thoroughly.
So lets talk about how
Google thinks about privacy
and compliance and security.
All of these topics
are interrelated.
Now, in a traditional
IT system, this usually
starts the other way around.
They'll say, I need to process
or protect credit card data,
so I need to build a
PCI DSS environment.
Now, that's a starting
point for many,
but for Google its
really reversed.
We look at our entire
platform, and we
say, what are the
strongest security
controls that we
can put in place
across our entire platform?
Next, we'll look at
the privacy controls--
the management of the data,
the access of the data--
and being able to
monitor that effectively.
Last but not least, we'll look
at the compliance frameworks
that we can put on top of it.
Because we have this
uniform security,
we can actually start
looking at things
like independent security
and compliance certifications
as applying across our platform
and not for specific solutions
or projects.
So let's talk about our
independent third-party
certifications.
So please, the big difference
I want to impart here
is that we operate a
single cloud environment.
We have one global cloud.
We do not have a German
cloud, or a health care cloud,
or a financial services
cloud, or even a gov cloud.
We operate a single
cloud infrastructure.
And what that means is,
again, not just having
a single baseline, but having
an audited baseline, again,
against multiple standards
by multiple auditors.
So lets talk through
a few of the biggies.
So we have the ISO
certifications.
This is an international
family of standards.
Starting with ISO 27101 we
have 114 security controls
looking at our platform.
ISO 27017 is an evolution
with cloud-specific security
controls.
ISO 27018 is the first
cloud data privacy standard.
So this is the
third-party audit that's
attesting that your data is only
being used per your instruction
and for no other purpose.
If you're more the
report-reading type of security
professional, we have our SO
1, SOC 2, and SOC 3 security
reports.
This is about 350 pages
of security goodness
that you can review
and, of course,
match to your controls
or your requirements.
If you'd like to process
credit card data,
we have PCI DSS certification.
Of course, we have the
most recent certification.
And we operate at the
highest merchant level,
so we can meet your requirements
in terms of credit card
processing.
If you're a health care
professional, we have HIPAA.
We actually support the
requirements under HIPAA,
so we will enter into a BAA.
We just recently attained
our high-trust certification
focused on health care data.
Last but not least, and this
is a large differentiation
for our platform, is
FedRAMP authorization.
So FedRAMP is the
security standard
that's used for protecting data
at both the federal, state,
and local levels.
Now, on other platforms, they
have very specific government
clouds that meet
these standards.
At Google, we have
a global platform.
So all of our data
centers, our services
that are scoped under
FedRAMP, are all
covered by these protections.
And we make these same
services, of course,
available to all customers,
not just government agencies.
So if you're a bank
or in health care,
your data is being protected
to the same standard
that we use for
the US government.
But it's not just FedRAMP.
You have multiple audits--
the FedRAMP audit, the ISO
audits, the SOC audits--
multiple checks,
multiple times to ensure
that your data is being
protected at the standards that
have been promised.
Now, these are the independent
third-party certifications.
We also have a lot of
regulatory engagement.
So being on that
single cloud platform
is very important because
we have the exact same story
that we can bring to
all of the regulators
globally across
different industries.
We're working with
national banks.
We're working with health
care oversight authorities.
We're working with privacy
authorities in Europe.
We're working with them not
just to explain our platform
and to quantify and
validate our contracts,
but again, we want to
have a consistent picture
for both compliance and security
across multiple geographies.
So if you're a
multinational organization,
you can have one
solution that's going
to be able to protect
all of your users,
rather than just having
something that is regional.
All right.
So speaking of something
that is a national level
and topical of late, I'd
like to talk about the GDPR.
The GDPR is the EU General
Data Protection Regulation.
This affects and protects
the personally-identifiable
information of
European nationals.
Basically, it puts in
controls and restrictions
on what can be done
with their data.
And of course, it
gives them rights
to be protected and notified
if there are things like data
breaches or security incidents.
Now, Google has been
working very hard,
and we are compliant with this
regulation, both as a company
and as a provider of services
via our enterprise cloud.
Now, this matters
to most customers
because oftentimes most
companies are actually
interacting or collecting
this type of information.
But again, you do not need
to make that differentiation.
Because we operate
as one cloud, we're
protecting all data to the same
level that the GDPR requires,
not just a specific subset.
So again, this is about
making things easier for you.
The GDPR is evolutionary,
not revolutionary.
For years, Google has been
compliant with the EU Data
Protection Directive,
the regulation that
came before the GDPR, and
we've been working for years
to become complying with the
GDPR as a cloud provider.
Now, when I say
it's evolutionary,
it's evolutionary in a very
positive term for both data
subjects and for
you as a customer.
Under the old law, the Data
Protection Directive, only you,
the customer, were
responsible for compliance.
You were also responsible
for paying all these fines.
Under the GDPR,
this is all changed.
security and compliance
are a shared responsibility
between you and Google.
For the areas that Google
is responsible for,
we're responsible for directly
to the privacy authorities.
If there is some sort
of incident or problem,
it's Google who will
be held responsible
and Google who'll
be paying the fine.
We're here to partner with
you to help mitigate that risk
and, of course, protect
your information.
OK.
I think that's all for today.
I hope you learned a
lot today about what
you need to know about
staying compliant.
And thank you for your time.
MIKE AIELLO: Hi.
My name is Mike Aiello.
I'm the director of product
management for Cloud Security.
I'm here today to talk about
securing and sharing your data.
So as a chief security officer,
chief information officer,
chief risk officer you need
to manage risks differently
when you move to Google Cloud.
This is where most of your new
analysis and benefit of moving
to the Cloud is
going to come from,
but this drives changes
in enterprise culture,
in audit, governance,
administrative control.
And in order to
manage these risks,
you need to think hard
about what the root
cause of most of the risks are.
And we find it comes
from three sources--
poor data management practices,
unauthorized access control
and access control setup, and
unencrypted data on the cloud.
At Google, we're
proud to say that we
have an array of solutions with
addressing these concerns that
are part of the shared
responsibility between the user
of Google Cloud and
Google Cloud itself.
So let's go through them.
First, we want to talk about
the exceptional opportunity
for customer understanding,
product design, manufacturing,
planning-- there's a
whole bunch of benefits
that you get from
moving to Cloud.
And the core of that is
the analytics workflow
coming from Cloud.
But this also means that you
have more data in more places.
Previously, it was only on-prem.
Now, it's on-prem and in-cloud
and across potentially multiple
clouds.
And a big part of the
reason you do this
is because you want to
enable data sharing.
The reality is in order to
get real value out of Cloud,
you need to move
sensitive information
or private information
to Cloud or anonymize
versions of private
information in Cloud.
One of the examples
that we have is we
worked with a
health care customer
who took more than two years
to simply identify and discover
the private and sensitive
information that they
had in their
enterprise before they
began their adoption of Cloud.
At Google, we've invested
deeply in machine learning
and artificial intelligence to
create tools and products that
make moving to Cloud
easier and make
the data discovery and data
anonymization aspects easier.
What you're seeing here is a
output of one of our products
called the Data
Loss Prevention API,
which has automatically
discovered
sensitive information in a file
that was passed through the API
and automatically in-place,
format-preserving redacted
that information.
So you can see that the phone
numbers have been redacted,
except for the
first three digits,
and email addresses and
social security numbers
have been redacted.
This makes it much
easier to tell
the story of securely operating
analytics environments
in the Cloud because
you can do so
on anonymized and redacted data.
We're also deeply
invested in making sure
that you have
transparency into when
a Googler accesses your data.
So we've invested in a product
called Access Transparency,
which you can enable, which
gives you a notification
whenever a Googler accesses your
data-- for example, if you send
in a support ticket asking for
help with a specific storage
bucket that you have.
So we're excited about having
tools and products that
help you discover and
classify your information
and, additionally, giving
you enhanced transparency
when you keep sensitive
information in Google Cloud.
Now let's talk about
access control--
the idea that
people should access
what they need for their
jobs and nothing else.
It's a good fundamental
principle of security.
At its core, it's defining who
can do what on which resource.
So if you think
about who-- that's
the identity of
the user-- can do
what-- that's the action--
on which resource--
this is the resource within
the Cloud, storage process, et
cetera.
We have two key
principles that we'd
like to communicate about this.
First is establish the most
granular access policies
you can.
It's the principle
of least privilege.
And we provide an identity
and access management
solution to do this.
And then second is employ
multifactor authentication
to protect against phishing.
We found that this reduces
one of the most common attack
factors that we see
in 2018 significantly.
Finally, let's talk
about securing the bits--
encryption.
59% of companies today lack
an enterprise-wide encryption
strategy.
That's not good.
There's many companies
out there that
don't have a story they can
tell their board about data
being encrypted by default
across the entire enterprise.
You'll be happy to know that
as you move your data to Google
Cloud we take care of that.
We encrypt the
data by default. We
encrypt it with the same
processes and procedures
we use to encrypt
data across Google.
And we've spent a long time
working on these processes
and procedures.
We have a core
principle that you
should have control of the keys
that encrypt your data if you
so choose.
And we provide a range
of management options
for those keys.
So by default, like I
mentioned, your data
is encrypted by REST with
keys that Google manages.
At the other extreme is, you can
bring your own encryption keys.
This gives you the
maximum control.
You're providing
the key material
which encrypts your data.
And in the middle, we provide a
customer-managed encryption key
option, where we generate
the keys for you,
and you can control the
rotation and revocation periods
around these keys.
So in order to encrypt your
data and secure your data,
you need a range of options.
From a fundamental
perspective, the data
is encrypted by
default at Google.
And we can help you in
each of these choices
that you have as you talk about
encryption with your customer
base, with your board,
and with Google.
And we see every permutation
of encryption key management
that folks can think of.
Folks have come to us
and talked about how
they want encryption
to work, and we
believe our product suite solves
the vast majority of these use
cases.
And if it doesn't
solve all of them,
please come back and
talk to our team,
and we will work to make
the products better.
So with that, I wanted
to say thank you.
And I wanted to hand
it over to Reena,
who's going to talk about how
to work securely from anywhere.
REENA NADKARNI:
Thank you, Michael.
And hello, everyone.
I am Reena Nadkarni, product
management lead on the G Suite
team.
G Suite is Google's
productivity suite.
It includes all of the products
that you're familiar with,
like Gmail, Calendar, Google
Drive, Docs, and Editors,
with extra controls for
enterprise users and enterprise
admins.
My focus today is
primarily on security
and how to make it simple.
You can have all the
security tools in the world,
but they're only useful if
you actually deploy them.
We want to make security
simple, both for the IT admins,
as well as for the
enterprise end users.
So what can we do to make
security easy to use?
Is it possible to
change the paradigm
from the old world, where
employees are the greatest
source of vulnerability,
the most mistrusted area,
to switching it
around and making
them the front line of defense?
At Google, we have
a history of making
difficult things simple to use.
Think about quality
search results.
That's something
that's very complex,
has a lot of sophisticated
technology behind the scenes,
but we've made it really
simple for our end users.
Security is no exception.
To many, this might
seem counterintuitive.
Security implies levers, dials,
lots of rules, and engines.
Easy implies exactly
the opposite.
Making security easy
might scare some people,
but I would argue
that the failure
to not achieve this goal is
far worse because then security
gets in your way and people are
not really using the security
tools we make available.
So with great urgency, we're
driving towards the world
that solves this problem.
Let's think about the way
in which many people still
work today--
passwords being managed
across different systems.
Some systems require passwords
that have 12 characters.
Others want a mix of upper
and lower characters.
Some require special characters.
And many times people
simply pick passwords,
write them on a Post-it,
stick them in their cube
or on their screen.
Many people are still
using thumb drives for data
portability.
And countless hours
are being spent
in attending trainings
and developing
trainings around compliance--
the trainings that
I like to call
"thou shall not do x, y, or z."
So let's start to think about
how we get control over all
these issues and how we can
solve these problems by knowing
the risks.
To understand the landscape
a little bit better,
let's look at what's
been happening
in the world of data breaches
and the world of ransomware.
There has been a 15x increase in
ransomware losses between 2015
to 2017, the last
couple of years.
Employees are more
vulnerable than ever.
90% of all reported
breaches were
caused by unintentional
employee negligence.
These bad actors prey on
your vulnerable employees.
Data breaches, when
compounded over time,
are estimated to have
a collective cost
of $2.1 trillion by 2019.
So it's really
easy to understand
why we need solutions that
not only help the IT admins
but also empower the
enterprise end users.
So now let's see how Cloud
Native Solution can help.
In security, scale matters.
It's almost like we constantly
see these new attacks and flaws
from using old methods
and outdated patches.
This is because we are
running a network that carries
1/4 of the internet traffic.
We stop more than anyone else
and are uniquely equipped
to address them all.
Did you know that every minute
Gmail stops 10 million spam
and malicious emails from
reaching our end users?
We've also recently added
advanced spoofing protections
in Gmail.
We've added Gmail
Confidential, which
allows you to set
message expiration,
revoke sent messages, and also
limit attachment downloads
and forwarding to keep your
confidential data safe.
We talked a little
bit about scale.
The scale that we have
allows us to apply
advanced AI and ML techniques
to the domain of security.
As you know, machine
learning models
scale better based
on the data that you
have to train these models on.
Our machine learning
models train
on data generated from seven
products that have over
a billion monthly active users.
Secondly, when you think about
attacks, like DDoS attacks,
you want to have a
high-bandwidth network.
We have the network
that allows you
to watch 500,000 YouTube
videos in high definition
simultaneously.
And then think about
device protections.
We protect 3 billion
devices from URLs
with malicious
content every day.
And with Google, this
scale and security
is now available to protect
you, your corporation,
and your employees
and their data.
So let's talk about
some specific features
that we have to be able to
make your employees less
vulnerable and more powerful.
The first, I want to
start with a statistic--
zero.
Zero is the number
of account hijackings
we have seen detected or
reported from our customers
ever since they have
deployed security keys.
So this is a very simple
and very important
security protection that you
can use for your organizations.
Second, G Suite Data
Loss Prevention--
both in Gmail and
in Google Drive,
at scale we can
stop important data
from being exfiltrated
outside your organizations.
And we make it really simple
for you to set up these rules--
the DLP rules.
We have over 50
predefined content types
that cover confidential
data across the world
so that you can create very
easily those advanced DLP
rules.
But we also allow you
to create custom rules
so that you can protect data.
Let's say that you have a
confidential project name,
and you want to make certain
that the data related
to this project never goes
outside of your organization.
You can set up a DLP
rule to protect that.
And you can take a variety
of different actions.
For example, you can quarantine
that email from going out,
you can warn the user,
or you can do both.
And lastly, we now have
Security Center for G Suite.
What Security Center
for G Suite does,
is that first of all, it
has a set of dashboards
that consolidates data from
across the organization--
things like log-in audit,
mobile device management alerts,
as well as suspicious drive
activity-- all in one place.
So as an admin, you
can come in and get
a single view of the security
posture of your organization.
Second, we have consolidated
all the security
settings for your
organization in one place.
And we show you
Google-recommended best
practices of what those settings
should be to best protect
your organization.
So what you really
see is a health
check of your organization's
security settings,
all the settings in one
place, what Google recommends
are the best practices, as
well as what settings you have
and where you're deviating
from our best practices.
This has been really
useful for our IT admins
to get at a glance in one view.
And then finally, we have
created an investigation
tool that allows you to
very quickly take actions.
This is because when a
malicious email enters
into your organization,
the time that you
have to protect
your data requires
you to act very quickly.
So what we do is we allow the
admins to very quickly navigate
across different core pieces
of data, from mobile logins
into suspicious
drive activities,
and narrow down the
data that you're seeing
and very quickly take actions--
bulk actions, like
deleting emails.
Now, clearly this is a
very powerful capability,
and so we want to
make sure that it's
available only to the
super admins with very
delegated and privileged access.
So we talked about three things.
First, how you can
protect your organization
by deploying security keys.
Second, how you can
proactively set up
DLP rules to better protect
your organization's data.
And finally, how G Suite
Security Center helps
your organization get a one-stop
view of the security posture
and very quickly act upon
malicious incidences.
With that, I want to
thank you for watching.
I really hope you
enjoyed this talk.
And we'll end with some insights
from one of our customers,
the City of Los Angeles.
I'd like to now hand it
over to Ted Ross, who is
their general manager and CEO.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TED ROSS: My name
is Ted Ross, and I
am chief information officer
at the City of Los Angeles.
As the IT department for
the second largest city
in the United States, we
have plenty of challenges.
We're relied upon by many
other city departments.
That includes LA
Police Department,
libraries, recreation and parks,
building and safety, planning,
and many others.
In the beginning, people
thought of the cloud
as being something a little
more risky because your data is
no longer on premise,
something that you can touch,
but we're really
way past that point.
Security in Cloud is
exponentially better
than what most organizations
can provide on premise.
In 2018, we moved
our financial system
into the cloud, which
means hundreds of thousands
of transactions every year
are running out of the cloud.
By moving data up
into the cloud,
not only do we get a low-cost,
pay-as-you-go infrastructure
that's secure and resilient,
but we also get access to great
machine learning and artificial
intelligence tools that allow
us to gain much more
insight into our operations,
how we run our city, the
decisions that we make,
and we can do so with powerful
tools that we wouldn't be able
to access within
our data center.
In 2017, we had a
very unique situation.
Two multi-alarm fires
occurred in Los Angeles
at the same time.
We had to get communications out
to over 150,000 residents who
had to be evacuated.
So while we did it with
all the traditional means
of news stories and
radio reports, et cetera,
we were missing a
digital solution.
We leveraged Google Maps to
very quickly put together
layers, very simple layers,
to communicate where
the fire evacuations were.
The use of Google Maps
for fire evacuation
was so effective
that we actually
had over three million
views within 36 hours.
And honestly, you will
not find such a high level
of consumption for almost
anything government does.
We feel that cloud
infrastructure is absolutely
the way of the future.
It allows us to deliver great
technology that's robust,
it's resilient to disasters,
and it scales at internet scale.
We find G Suite tools to be
an extremely effective way
of empowering our employees.
Here's a service and
here's a tool that
makes our employees
much more productive,
whether they're sharing
documents or sharing
spreadsheets,
sharing information,
their ability to do this so
quickly and so efficiently
really is much more cost
effective for the taxpayer.
For an organization of our
size, lightweight tools
like Google's gives us
tremendous opportunities.
Honestly, the more we
move into the cloud,
the more we see the benefits
from a resiliency perspective,
from a security
perspective, and just
from an accessibility
perspective.
[MUSIC PLAYING]